[Música]
o
soy seguramente igual que ustedes cumplo
enemy y las funciones n mil roles todos
los días soy hija soy esposa soy mamá
soy hermana soy amiga no soy nada fue el
otro mundo pero antes que todo esto soy
persona y soy mujer y esto me ha llevado
junto con mi carrera profesional que
ahorita les platicaré un poquito a irme
interesando precisamente plática ahorita
mi anterior speaker en la historia en
este caso de los derechos de las mujeres
y cómo es que hoy por hoy estamos
paradas en un mundo de posibles de
posibilidades pero que no siempre
existieron y que además nunca fueron
regalados vengo de una familia pues de
muchos valores yo creo que igual que
ustedes también como sabemos vivimos en
una sociedad muy folclórica como ahorita
ya nos quedó claro y me encanta de donde
celebramos mucho como sabemos la unión
familiar
el matrimonio yo soy una persona que
cree en el matrimonio para toda la vida
y al mismo tiempo también como abogada
siempre les digo como abogada y como
persona y como mujer
también creo en el divorcio amigable
cuando por alguna situación
extraordinaria el matrimonio no puede
continuar qué quiere decir el matrimonio
amigable la base de todo esto es que
creo que la familia es para siempre
quien coincide con que las familias para
siempre ayúdenme levantando su mano al
margen de cómo esté funcionando de sí
separados y juntos si no hay lo que
demás eso nunca se juzga pero la familia
es para siempre y yo creo que esa es una
de las principales
pilares que tenemos en nuestra comunidad
mexicana que somos muy de celebrar la
familia y bueno como me voy a
interesando nuestros temas bueno en el
estudiar derecho trabajo como les
mencionaron ahorita mención favor de
presentarme en el supremo tribunal de
justicia del estado entonces como
abogada mi camino profesional me ha ido
llevando sobre todo en el en el derecho
civil y familiar más más pues yo creo
que por lo que les comentaba que vengo
como de una familia muy unida y que
celebramos mucho todo esto me fui
involucrando muchísimo en el desarrollo
del derecho familiar posteriormente
estudié un máster para especializarme en
esta área y también esto me fue metiendo
en el mundo de la igualdad de género lo
que me va a llevar a platicarles un
poquito más esta tarde de la igualdad de
género y del feminismo una cosa que a mí
me disgusta mucho es que cuando he
escuchado muchas pláticas y talleres de
feminismo y mucha gente dice que hablar
de feminismo es muy difícil que es como
la política que vamos a salir peleados y
que como el fútbol y siento que eso ha
generado en muchas personas una una idea
equivocada de lo que es el feminismo
entonces por eso y hoy quiero decirles
que hablar de feminismo y hablar de
de mujeres no tiene por qué ser
complicado es bien simple fíjense el
feminismo y me encantó cómo lo explicó
emma watson yo creo que la mayoría de
ustedes quizás ubiquen a emma watson
sino por el nombre de actriz se acuerdan
dejar marioni en harry potter bueno ella
es la actriz emma watson este ella es
una activista muy importante a nivel
internacional y en su conferencia de la
onu en la organización de las naciones
unidas me encantó como lo explicó yo le
dije si el feminismo es la creencia de
que hombres y mujeres debemos de tener
las mismas oportunidades y los mismos
derechos
es precisamente esta creencia el
movimiento para proteger que la igualdad
política económica y social entre los
sexos
es muy curioso esta situación les voy a
decir porque yo creo que aquí la mayoría
coincidimos
espero que hombres y mujeres valemos lo
mismo estamos de acuerdo sí o sí gracias
a valemos lo mismo porque somos personas
hoy en día somos conscientes de eso y
por existir valemos lo mismo pero si
mujeres y que por tanto debiéramos tener
las mismas posibilidades para
desarrollarnos en cualquier ámbito que
queramos simplemente para desarrollar
nuestras metas y crecer como personas
ser mejores día a día estamos de acuerdo
que la mayoría pensamos eso estamos de
acuerdo también en que hay tratados
internacionales para hablar es
particularmente derechos de las mujeres
hay muchas leyes especialmente para los
derechos de las mujeres y para la
igualdad en el artículo cuarto día se va
a salir la abogada oigan pero yo espero
que la mayoría lo sepa y si no para eso
estoy aquí para compartir el artículo
cuarto de la constitución política
federal en nuestro país habla del
derecho a la igualdad y habla de que
está prohibido en nuestro país
discriminar por otras razones como
comentaba también al principio nuestra
expositora
por muchas razones por el color de piel
etcétera pero entre otras razones si la
que a mí me interesa sobre todo es esta
prohibido discriminar por razón de sexo
es decir por ser hombre y ser mujer
entonces qué pasa que está tan curioso
que a pesar de que hay tantas leyes y ha
habido tantos movimientos que ha
progresado el movimiento feminismo del
feminismo por muchas diversas etapas y
que ya todo el mundo pensamos como un
poquito más abierto en cuanto a que
somos iguales porque entonces no les
parece que es bastante curioso que siga
habiendo hoy en día tantísima
discriminación contra las mujeres
tantísima violencia contra las mujeres y
tantísima desigualdad desigualdad de
género me refiero y por qué dices marcia
que sigue habiendo tantísima desigualdad
bueno a ver si coincide conmigo o no si
nos vamos fíjense al ámbito laboral lo
cierto es que las empresas si no lo digo
yo están las estadísticas y les puedo
pasar a quien guste al final esté un
poquito las fuentes de mi charla y lo
que venimos estudiando hace algunos años
es muy interesante las estadísticas
dicen que en las empresas de la
iniciativa privada hombres y mujeres
ganan distinto a pesar de hacer un mismo
trabajo las mujeres en el 2017 ganaban
en promedio 30% menos
con las mismas capacitaciones con los
mismos estudios y por hacer un mismo
trabajo que obedece a una razón de
género a que nosotros socialmente en una
cultura tan rica como es también es muy
machista
hay que decirlo y sigue prevaleciendo la
idea en las empresas de que una mujer no
pasa nada que gane un poquito menos
porque tiene un marido en su casa que es
el principal encargado de traer la lana
a la casa pero si el hombre es el que es
el compañero y trabaja igual no pues hay
que darle más porque pues él tiene que
pagar las colegiaturas y tienen que
pagar todo eso no es muy injusto esto
que por la mínima preparación estamos
ganando distinto
marcia pero bueno eso de las empresas
bueno vámonos a los gobiernos a las
instituciones públicas donde vemos la
diferencia ahí es mucho más difícil que
ganemos distinto porque yo ya como saben
también está muy avanzado en el tema de
la transparencia en nuestro país y ahí
ya va encaminado importantemente
entonces ya las nóminas son
completamente públicas para quien la
queremos checar y puedes ver que se les
paga igual a hombres y mujeres por un
mismo trabajo pero fíjense lo
interesante aquí la desigualdad de
género se sigue viendo ahí ustedes nada
más cheque en la cantidad de personas si
ustedes ven un presídium se van a
acordar de mí la próxima vez que chequen
y se van a dar cuenta y esos los puedo
que quiera asegurar la cantidad de
mujeres que hay sentadas en puestos de
dirección en puesto de toma de
decisiones
eso está interesante porque en las en
las oficinas de gobierno en muchas áreas
las mujeres es posible que sean más que
los hombres check en línea es posible
que sean más pero cuando va ascendiendo
la jerarquía y cuando hay que tomar
decisiones la inmensa mayoría son
hombres y en muchos plenos hay nueve
hombres ocho hombres
una mujer y hasta a veces nos atrevemos
o se atreven a decir que para cumplir la
cuota de género o sea no es porque
genuinamente se crea en las capacidades
de las mujeres hay desigualdad y saben
cuál es la peor de las desigualdades hoy
en día y la que más nos aqueja y por la
que estoy para que hoy no es la
desigualdad en las leyes porque ahí ya
ha habido muchas reformas no la
desigualdad en el gobierno porque se
está más o menos pero se está trabajando
ahí pero en la peor desigualdad que
vivimos hoy en día y la que me interesa
platicar hoy
es la desigualdad en el hogar
esa es la verdadera desigualdad que no
nos permite avanzar como comunidad y
crecer y desarrollarnos
aquí me estoy refiriendo yo creo que la
mayoría de las hay si no ha hecho
encuestas ese es mi criterio personal
pero creo que en la mayoría de las
familias mexicanas sigue imperando aún
la idea de que la mujer es la principal
y la única respondió quizá no la única
pero sí la principal y la responsable
del cuidado de los hijos de la formación
de las criaturas de todo lo que es el
quehacer doméstico de que si se enfermó
el abuelito la abuelita es la encargada
de también cuidarlos incluso también los
suegros porque el amor y todo lo que sé
pero yo la encarga y el papá entonces el
señor es el principal encargado del
sustento del sostén económico y es
cierto que muchas mujeres ya tenemos las
posibilidades de estar aquí para se
enfrente que tenemos espacio que salimos
a trabajar fuera de la casa pero que
creen que está generando esto que llegan
las mujeres del trabajo igual de
cansadas que el hombre y entonces esa
mujer se está aventando una doble
jornada así se le conoce en términos de
género porque llega y están bien las
comidas también las tareas están bien
los lonches las las mujeres saben de lo
que estoy hablando ahora que si las
pañaleras la ropa no pusiste es la que
se acuerda se está sucio el uniforme y
si no y no
estén mal porque no quiero algo que
siempre quiero hacer énfasis es hablar
de igualdad de género nunca nunca es un
tema de pelearnos o enfrentarnos hombres
y mujeres al contrario si algo si una
idea se pueden llevar de mí hoy es que
hablar de igualdad de género y hablar de
derechos de las mujeres es hablar de
equipo y de corresponsabilidad familiar
porque es donde nos urge hacer el cambio
sí porque este esta situación de que no
avanzamos tanto como ya debiéramos en
términos de igualdad que está generando
mujeres frustradas agotadas de mal humor
porque están cansadas y más y porque no
hablan y porque tienen todo el tiempo
como ocupadas
todo el tiempo con esta carga mental y
que créanme hablar de igualdad de género
como les digo no es nada más hablar de
mujeres porque la desigualdad nos afecta
a hombres ya mujeres más a mujeres es
cierto lo dicen las estadísticas pero
también afecta a los hombres de qué
manera les afecta al hombre la empresa
tremendamente el estereotipo de que
tiene que ser el único encargado del
sostén económico como les mencionaba
entonces aparte es una ley que el hombre
viene cargando con el estereotipo de que
si se le ocurre
hablar de sus emociones y mostrar sus
sentimientos ya pierden masculinidad los
hombres saben de lo que estoy hablando
es algo que no se habla mucho pero la
carga de sostener una familia
económicamente es tremenda psicológica y
emocionalmente y si por algo estamos
pasando una situación en la casa en la
que no está alcanzando el dinero él es
el principal dueño y entonces que genera
esto también hombres tristes también
hombres deprimidos y entonces esto
finalmente nos está generando
parejas que están chocando en familias
que están en crisis por eso desde mi
opinión el tema de la desigualdad de
género nos debe doler y nos debe de
ocupar muchísimo desde las casas y desde
los hogares que claro que el gobierno
también tiene que ver desde luego el
gobierno que haga su parte para el final
del día por eso celebro tantísimo estos
eventos y estos espacios para un poquito
tratar de llamar la atención de todos
ustedes e invitarlos cuál es mi
invitación cuál es para mí la solución
punto número uno hacer conciencia de
esto que por eso reiteró el
agradecimiento está aquí hacer
conciencia de esto para tratar de
ponernos esto está esta visión esta
perspectiva que se llama perspectiva de
género de ver las cosas un poquito y de
cuestionarlo lo que hacemos si hago lo
que hago lo hago por un patrón social lo
hago porque tengo que ser femenina
porque tengo que ser masculino porque
desde que nacemos acuérdense te ponen
las ropitas el estilo rosita desde ella
se fregó vas encajando en este esquema
de ser femenina o de ser masculina
es la realidad como todos cambiar esto
tratando de visibilizar esta situación y
también desde el lenguaje oigan
importantísimo yo sé que muchas personas
piensan que era ocurrencia de focs esto
de decir todos y todas pero que creen
les tengo una mala noticia no fue idea
de fox de hecho bueno hubiera sido que
fuera esto idea de una de nuestros
presidentes pero no realmente esto viene
detrás de investigaciones
internacionales de defensa de derechos
de las mujeres y de lo que procura el
lenguaje incluyente es precisamente
visibilizar que hay mujeres les voy a
platicar rapidito la historia de
marianita mariani para que veamos un
poquito de lo explicarles la importancia
del lenguaje incluyente
marianita era una niña que estaba en
segundo de primaria en su salón de
clases cuando les dice la maestra oiga
niños estamos organizando ya es de los
equipos de fútbol ya está abierta la
convocatoria entonces todos los niños
que quieran participar en el fútbol
vengan se formar para tomarles sus datos
se para a marianita la maestra que cree
esto la regrese a marianita no
escuchaste que dije niños el fútbol es
para los niños las niñas no tienen
cabida en el fútbol no se regresa
mariani está muy triste
a su asiento ya se asientos siguen las
clases tiembla y sigue el recreo niños
ya pues se pueden salir todos al recreo
todos los niños se pueden salir al
recreo se salen todos y marianita se
queda sentado
marianita no escucha hasta que todos los
niños pues no dijo que los niños lo hace
hablo de los niños y ahí yo no cabía
para el fútbol pero ahorita que dice
todos los niños vayan ser recreo ahí sí
que po
me explico un poquito lo que estoy
tratando de decirles a lo que voy con
esto es que las mujeres ya estamos
acostumbradas a que se nos hable en
general pero la realidad es que nunca
tenemos certeza de que se nos esté
incluyendo no mientras no se digan las
mujeres o no se hable de las niñas
entonces no es que a mí me ofenda que me
digan abogado no me ofende pero la
realidad de las cosas es que no hay
ningún conflicto con que digamos
presidenta en vez de presidente yo sé
que a mucha gente le causa de ruido yo
sé que hay gente que diga es que nuestro
lenguaje en el español déjenme les digo
que ya ha habido muchos el análisis de
la lengua y no hay ninguna regla ningún
fundamento que diga qué hablar en
masculino incluye la mujer no existe son
costumbres y como tales las podemos ir
cambiando porque porque a través del
lenguaje finalmente es donde nosotros
expresamos lo que tenemos aquí y lo que
tenemos acá a través de los chistes
machistas a través de las bromitas a
través de que las mujeres nos sirven
para manejar no saben estaciones yo la
verdad soy experto en estacional pero lo
que les quiero decir es que más allá de
eso nos atrevamos a cuestionar por qué
hablamos como hablamos porque mucha
gente le hace ruido decir presidente en
vez de presidente perón
le causa conflicto decir sirvienta en
vez de sirviente
son ideas con los que los quiero dejar
son semillitas invitarles a
cuestionarlos invitar a cuestionar esto
porque al final del día este tema
necesita estar sobre la mesa y en mi
opinión no es nada más en la mesa como
les decía en los gobiernos nuestros
gobernantes sino en el centro de la mesa
en nuestra casa porque mientras que las
mujeres sigamos pensando que el hombre
ayuda cuando cambia dos pañales cuando
en realidad es también su trabajo nos
vamos a progresar mientras sigamos
pensando que hay que aplaudirle al
hombre que llega del trabajo y también
se dedica a bañar a los niños y ojo no
estoy diciendo que no lo reconozcamos
porque al final del día al matrimonio
como yo les dije al principio yo creo en
el matrimonio firmemente y creo que el
matrimonio vamos a servir eso es una
cosa otra distinta es hacer las cosas
porque te lo impone un rol social o
porque te lo imponen o estereotipo es
muy distinto hacer las cosas por amor si
me explico espero compartirles un
poquito espero
estarme explicando en la idea porque son
dos cosas muy distintas y la realidad es
cosas es la que les decía que el hombre
que llegue a su casa y viene de trabajar
y aparte se se pone a atender niños o
hace algo más o se queda horas extras en
su trabajo se le aplaude porque es muy
dedicado pero a la mujer que se queda
horas extras en su trabajo y que a parte
llega a cuidarse de los niños que se le
dice que está descuidando las criaturas
y está descuidando al marido entonces y
se va con otra pues
ella se lo buscó
quiero dejarlos con una última cosa que
me pareció muy importante no sé si
habían escuchado pero ya hay estudios
que analizan el índice de felicidad de
los distintos pueblos de las sociedades
y los países esto a mí me pareció
encantador porque yo soy un apasionado
también del desarrollo humano y me
pareció muy muy importante que los
países donde más alto índice o mejor
índice de felicidad tienen no es nada
más tiene que ver con clima con pobreza
con trabajo etcétera pero lo que es
mismo muy interesante es que los países
donde tienen más alto índice en temas de
igualdad de género que están mejor
funcionando como empresas y como
gobierno son también los países donde se
ha demostrado que la gente vive más
feliz
quiero dejarles con esto me encantaría
saber qué piensan todos y todas estoy
para servirles en mis redes sociales
como marcial benavides en instagram y en
facebook y estoy muy agradecida estar
aquí con ustedes muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]